ninja did an oopsie alinity
did an oopsy tekashi69 did a big oopsie
and smosh
oopsie my name is gloria boger
oopsie-doopsy let's bring on the news
pew news the most respected news source
on
youtube this just in everyone hates
ninja now
why because he's basically pewdiepie
unfunny screaming loud
obnoxious unself-aware colored hair
no because ninja gets people banned
that's right everybody if nina doesn't
like you in fortnite
he can get you banned like that he's the
thanos of
fortnite this all started because on
reddit a post said that this poor player
is about to get banned
because he emoted so let's review the
clip
watch for the email watch the email why
the email email emote
guys know these guys no oh my god dude
water look how big he's at building
look at him he's showing you he's
showing you the way dude wow
there's emo there it is
what an idiot how stupid can you be
what an idiot how stupid can you be to
use the e-mode in a video game
i've seen indisputable proof undeniable
evidence
it doesn't get more straight-up facts
than that and i run pew news i am the
most factual news source
on the planet now as it turns out he
wasn't stream sniping it was just a
random guy
get this just doing emotes and he made a
response
i guess the the moral lesson is not to
you're not supposed to
dance all right you can't dance this
this right here
the emotes it's it's not a thing that
you're allowed to do in
in fortnite when you kill someone and
have six spectators
it's not it's not allowed guys i'm sorry
so i bring it to you
you gotta always love when there's proof
you literally
what an idiot how stupid can you be
i'm i'm i'm going out of my way to make
sure this guy's man i see five
all right i see five if you leave this
game
right now i will not report you if you
leave if we witness you leave i will not
report you
but i will guarantee your ban if you
stay in this game
maybe he's not sniping maybe maybe he
killed me alone a soul squad and then
ben said do the emo and then he emoted
leave you guys if you guys want to unsub
for that get out of my stream
leave please go stop with someone else
so after this happened
another video on the fortnite subreddit
came up with 44 000
upvotes saying this is not clickbait
ninja got a player banned for having
higher pin
episodes banned the player only because
ninja reported him
this is proof that epic bans anyone who
ninja reports and does not review the
player so
after this people were pretty outraged
because you have someone
basically abusing their uh seemingly
abusing their power
on the platform or twitch or fortnite
you know
ninjas the face of fortnite in a way and
basically abusing that power
and getting people banned so a lot of
people were very mad
very bad hashtag ben ninja
hashtag stop ninja hashtag we will
resist
hashtag not my number one player in the
game
stop buying ninja merch and headbands
right freaking now this ends now we can
no longer support this tyrant
on the platform nin gabe that's right we
will call him
ningy no to be fair
at this point it's pretty understandable
that people are upset he's acting like
an idiot
but as it turns out epic games responded
to this saying that the person that was
banned for the ping
was someone else that got banned but had
changed their name it's a bit confusing
but basically
they look into every single report and
they don't ban someone just because it's
ninja who says ban this person they ban
if they did something wrong but at this
time it looked like
ben india did this but he actually did
even though he did report
anyway i think the problem here is that
ninja said he guarantees i'm going out
of my way to get this
guy back making it seem like he had that
power when
epic games come in and say no we don't
treat him differently or at least his
reports differently which is good and
they shouldn't and they have really no
reason to go against that
ninja then made a response i have not
gotten anyone banned that i said i was
going to get banned
for not for no reason at all it's not
funny it's annoying
and i i do i call out stream snipers
less than any other streamer
literally the one time i have a couple
drinks
and get a little mad
like dude it's a total
joke man it's like now i'm the guy who
calls it every time and ever it's so
funny to be like
no big dude the amount of 12 year olds
that are commenting on twitter and
instagram
about stream snipers blows my mind
oh ninja why
why introducing
felix apology service need help to write
your apology
just contact felix he's got experience
expertise anyway i think the hypocrisy
here is that if
anyone else but ninja did this no one
would care
and i can kind of relate to that
hypocrisy and to that frustration of
getting a different treatment just
because you're the person on top but
that's inevitably the situation if
someone else reported someone
in the game saying i'm gonna get you
banned uh
no one would care but he did say it in a
way like he had that power it's like a
fiction of
i have this power that i can use because
i'm ninja
and then combine that with the fact that
this fake story came out because it
looked like
he got someone banned when he actually
didn't that's why everyone jumped on
ninja and hating on him
even though he's practically doing what
a lot of streaming does it doesn't make
it okay
but i think he could have just explained
this calm and rationally instead
of uh getting pissed off about it and i
think no one probably would have cared
and that's essentially the problem no
one cares i don't even care why am i
talking about it
moving on linity who would have thought
alinity would be back on punish i had no
idea if you guys remember elinidy
she copy striked me can your chair do
this
seriously he just said that
i'm gonna copy strike this guy
just for that word gonna copy strike him
yo can we copy strike pewdiepie's latest
video
like right now this is very similar to
ninja isn't
it someone boasting about doing
something bad like they have that power
and like yeah i'm gonna copy strike him
although to be fair i did get copy
strike so yeah
then i called her out for basically just
sexualizing her content for kids
and i got called out in return by vice
that's right
vice out of all places thought they had
the moral high ground saying that
pewdiepie is teaching his audience that
women are
asking for it basically because yeah i
called her out for
sexualizing her content and uh now
as it turns out she's doing the same
thing okay
look at this so you're supposed i'm
gonna do it this way
you're supposed jesus christ all right
so later in this clip
this happens oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
what was that
[Music]
i want to buy hey alinity i hope you
remember
you sold me a leopard bra many years ago
i had offered you very good money then
smiley winky face
and i wanted to ask if you'd like to
how could i how could i accuse this poor
woman
she then basically went on to admit that
this happened i don't even remember what
the bra looked like
remember when she felt offended for
being
i wonder who she's hooking up with from
twitch staff
she's broken so many rules on twitch if
it was a guy they would have been banned
years ago
if it was a guy he would have told the
label and by and by now
the way twitch handles things right now
i mean i don't think she deserves to get
banned for this to be fair
i'm just bringing up this issue in
general i feel like
the way twitch is running their website
something is about uh
there's a bubble waiting to be broken
that's not the expression but whatever
next news tekashi69 faces 32 years to
life in prison on racketeering
and firearm charges takeshi the rapper
famous for his songs like
got it stiffy uh and the rapper famous
for
underage sexual misconduct the final
boss
of the soundcloud rap game potential
host for meme
review that's right package 69 was
supposed to host meme review
and now he goes to jail for 32 years
possibly
coincidence i don't think so someone put
takashi 69 in jail to prevent him from
hosting meme review and i cannot pretend
that i'm okay with this
all memes aside tekashi69 uh is facing a
long time in prison possibly
uh because he was involved in a gang i
don't know exactly what he did it hasn't
really been confirmed
but the term racketeering is usually
used in regards to mafia
as a way to arrest uh the top guys
because the the smaller ones or or the
small fries will never squeal
and they'll just get replaced constantly
and they never get
the guy on top so they have this
racketeering i don't really know what
i'm talking about
now tekashi offered 1.7 million from his
bank account and his passport
and his skittle machine and his hair
coloring shampoo
i just thought it was funny rappers are
all about money bradley has 2 million on
his account
i'm not saying that's little but in
considering how much
he flexes and all the rappers flex he's
like really that's all you have on your
account
if you remember takashi is it takashi or
takashi i don't know
he pleaded guilty on uh using a child in
a sexual performance
and he also agreed during that to stop
affiliating with
known gang members now he faces a couple
of charges one for racketeering
conspiracy which could lead to 20 years
in prison
one for using firearms which could be
life in prison and violent crime in nato
and there's a couple of charges
the lawyer says that he's completely
innocence of the charges
being brought against him and that he
just portrays being a gangster to
promote his music and he's not actually
there is evidence of him filming a
robbery at gunpoint in times square and
there is evidence of him being
affiliated with this gang
i guess it just remains to see what the
fbi has
on him one thing i feel in life no two
things
i'm not gonna i fear god and i fear the
fbi
only two things i'm scared in life
god first and the fbi
when they were praying for me yes and
that was i guess we'll see
takashi 6 9's appearance on meme review
in 32 years
i'll be waiting don't you worry or
possibly from jail that would be pretty
epic
from what i understand is that he could
face probably minimum three years
from the charges that he has against him
most likely if he's lucky
or maybe they work out some sort of deal
but it looks like takashi
will serve time in prison regardless
passing the question on to you guys what
do you think this is so sad
last but not least smosh is gone
i'm just kidding defy media is shutting
down it will lay off
employees uh welcome to peonies everyone
where we talk about the news
uh a couple weeks ago if you don't know
defy media is a company that owns
smosh everyone knows smosh it's smosh i
didn't know about the five media until i
heard about the honest trailers
sexual abuse allegations that came out
against andy signore
that they were owned by the fi media as
well ironically andy was one of the
people that called me out on twitter for
being rotten
although these were allegations and we
don't know if they're true or not
and also andy apparently is suing defy
media over his sexual harassment firing
saying that if i did not do any
investigation before firing him
saying that in the company they
encouraged a culture
of casual sex with fans stating that
high level management staff and
shareholders
were engaged in sexual and otherwise
personal relationships with fans interns
and employees well i guess employees is
fine but that is interesting
i wonder how that lawsuit is going to
end up defy media
now shut off no warning no sign all the
people
that work on smush all the people
involved had no
warning it was just bye-bye you're gone
which all is always a great sign of a
company really caring about their
employees
anthony padilla who is one of the
founders of smosh
a wonderful dude they're both incredible
people although anthony left
defy media in smosh a year ago i think
and he told me a couple things about it
as well and i remember it seemed
so when he left it was like yeah i
understand why he would leave but now
he came out finally and said what was
wrong with uh the fire media and
messed up smosh essentially one of the
that was the biggest channel on youtube
i guess just to start back at the
beginning ian and i
sold smosh in 2011 to
what eventually became defy media
and we sold it
for stock in the company which was great
so i sold it for
zero dollars selling for stock
means that it's completely valueless
unless that company goes public
which it never did i sold smosh
for zero dollars damn i can't believe
that that's crazy
anthony went on talking about some more
details about what the company
did that was really wrong and scummy
they convinced us to
start an indiegogo campaign to raise
money to start
an ios game that hadn't even been
conceived they just saw that some
other youtuber had started a kickstarter
to raise money and they're like ooh
you can do that too get some money from
people and there was no
idea for that game they were just like
put your face and reputation on the line
beg people for for money for a game that
has
no concept whatsoever and we'll just
figure it out later let's just see how
much we could raise
i can't even imagine all that stress
that must have caused
why did they take that money in the
first place
i don't know they owe a ton of money to
a whole bunch of people
you can google it for yourself and if i
did a lot of other shitty things i
forgot to mention they try to take my
personal twitter account oh yeah i
remember he told me about this
crazy this makes me reminded of how glad
i
am to have gone solo as a youtuber
maybe at least the way i make videos you
don't i think this applies to most
people
you don't need to work with a big
company it's it's a similar story to
anthony you know you get flown to la and
someone says like oh we can do this for
you that's
this is really cool we can really help
you grow your thing you're like oh that
that seems like a great idea
and then eventually you ended up doing
something that you didn't want at all
luckily
uh i got out of it through my
controversies
and i'm so much better off now i i enjoy
everything so much more now and and uh i
can really see
that frustration you see more and more
often now youtubers becoming independent
you have the people working at buzzfeed
doing their own stuff and it's basically
the same production
uh people doing the same thing people
being independent how great
my biggest advice to anyone who thinks
about selling their brand
don't you're better off independent
you're going to end up
uh doing a bunch of stuff that you don't
want to do and money is really not
everything
that was it for pew news hope you guys
enjoyed this episode
what do you guys think as always passing
the question on
to you guys but before that you also
have to buy my merch that's right
to comment on this video you have to buy
the merch
and comment i bought all the merch haha
epic
lull we got the hat i don't know if you
notice it but i'm wearing a pioneer's
hand
it's very nice it's very good designed
by me that's right it sounds ridiculous
to say that because this
is a logo but i made it i made the logo
and i think it looks pretty cool okay
shut up
it's called minimal i'm very proud of it
i think it looks very cool we all have a
long sleeves and t-shirts so as well so
check those out i really really like how
they came out i'm very proud of this
collection i can't believe i just called
merch collection
i spent a lot of time making it okay i
hope you guys enjoy it if you want to
support puny's that's a great way to do
it i appreciate it very much
it's available for limited time and
black friday sale as well
thank you guys for watching bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you